hiya Johnny hi Craig no I didn't just buy
these clothes for this video I don't know
what you're talking about does you look amazing
this is what I'm used to seeing all the way
around the office can you pass me the scissors
yeah absolutely sorry I just I've had this
on my clothes for years yeah years I've had
it on always having to remind you to take
the tags off of clothes that you've had for
years and years it's a habit but this is what
I always wear hey speaking of oh clothes what
citizens of the reject Nation we are finally
gonna watch the Barbie movie the movie everyone
else has seen but we had our Comic-Con panel
as time went on we're like I guess we're not
watching this in the theaters I think we're
just gonna react to it I'm streaming and here
we are I'm so excited to see this really quick
I want to share this it's been our background
for a while my sister got me this uh Ken Barbie
doll Ryan Gosling version it was my birthday
recently so happy birthday to amwa I'm so
excited to see this I have had this muted
on all social media for the longest time the
only slither of a spoiler that I got was that
there's an hen song in here but I haven't
heard a single second of it not be nothing
I am ready for this so please go ahead leave
a like on this video that'd be very much appreciated
I'm not used to armrest ah subscribe click
the notification Bell so you get notified
when our next reaction is up here in the channel
because we're covering so much right now and
also thank you to prepper for helping us out
down these highlights lastly as always massive
thank you to all who have joined our patreon
page becoming super sexy rejects over there
you can catch the full-length Reaction watch
along re-sync up with your own copy of Barbie
we cover several things exclusive over there
with reaction highlights and watch along as
included thank you again to all joined let's
finally see with all the hype is about cannot
wait
[Music] are we starting off with these since
the beginning of time we are since the first
little girl ever existed there have been yes
I love that this is actually part of it the
girls who played with them could only ever
play it being mother
wow [Music] gorgeous she's an Amazon
other dolls mattered I'm very happy they committed
to this I was afraid it was just gonna be
a teaser bit
create transition Bobby changed every swim
in a Barbie and Barbie is all of these women
diversity what about Tori she has her own
money her own house her own career because
Barbie can be anything these are all Easter
eggs and references to real life jobs all
problems are feminism
[Music] thank you
well done Babs and here is one of those Barbies
now living her best day every day now she's
just one of those Barbies [Music]
it's a fun song is this completely unproblematic
lizzo come on we got important things to do
it's her even garbage day is glamorous in
Barbie land goes with everything beautiful
from man this production design is gorgeous
the shot the Tarantino shot you just look
so good on us
love it I like the symmetry of these shots
a lot yeah very Wes Anderson like
man this set is insane I just want to examine
every detail they're so good at personifying
like the imaginary play Vibe like the right
amount of things are real and fake yeah
[Music] great choreography it's nice to get
a song too that is like a theme song of the
main character
pink just looks get your vitamin C Barbie
or your vitamin A and D it's doing a good
job of capturing the appeal of an artifice
life nobody bothers to walk from down the
stairs and out the door Etc you just pick
them up and put them where you want them to
go Marilyn [Music] hi Barbie hi Skipper Skipper
yes her sister she was discontinued by Mattel
because a pregnant doll is just too weird
oh guess so little pregnant girls deserve
to see themselves in a toy as well everybody
turn to the party The Pink House you can ask
me any question you want so how come you're
so amazing
female friendship I have no difficulty holding
both logic and feeling at the same time [Laughter]
I can tell it's going to be very much a ride
hey awesome
Bobby has a great day every day but Ben only
has a great day yes if Barbie looks at him
oh ken hi Barbie hi Ken hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie get out of here oh hi Alan there
are no multiples of Alan he's just Alan he's
just Alan we all are check me out [Music]
oh what are you gonna do buddy catch that
wave boy
again oh [Music]
kid physics are the best oh looks like this
beach was a little too much Beach for you
Ken what's Beach off anyone who wants to beat
him up has to beat me off first I will beat
both of you up you can beat each other off
let's go
jeez Ken is extremely codependent no he's
so cool stay with me Barbie great not even
broken you'll be fine oh jeffer's not even
my job I know and it is not lifeguard which
is a common misconception I didn't know that
can I come to your house tonight sure sure
I don't have anything they planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies and
planned choreography oh my goodness
God this must have been fun to shoot [Music]
God got the star power in this movie oh is
this um is this like Some Like It Hot is this
a Marilyn Monroe like tribute I bet they're
gonna be a lot of like classic movie tribute
shots and sequences looking good Barbie thanks
guys [Laughter] [Music] [Laughter] such faces
he makes what's up cats
wow you can move yeah
[Applause] perfectly perfect and you look
so beautiful Barbie thanks Barbie I feel so
beautiful so supportive Best Day Ever and
so is yesterday and so is tomorrow and always
will be [Applause] but life is not perfect
whoa what a question
I'm just dying to dance those intrusive thoughts
will get you a way to cover it up existential
dread is always creeping I thought I might
stay over tonight why because we're girlfriend
boyfriend she did what I'm actually not sure
hurry up the president's here I am you're
welcome giant brush I can't I gotta go [Music]
saddy plays him keep telling yourself that
button Barbies I'm thinking about death anymore
that's how I go to sleep wow so it's also
gonna be a story about acceptance and realizing
what lies beyond your bubble
now wake up in my own world and wait for my
home girl [Laughter] Fleet Pariah people are
going to start noticing that you're not being
Peppy
I love that gag so much
I love how it's how it's her mind creating
all this yeah it's all just the perception
oh no oh girl you okay Come on Barbie let's
run towards the water okay what happens when
we get there oh what just happened she's a
paraplegic now
[Applause] fake vomit
I know I'm stereotypical Barbie and therefore
don't form conjectures concerning the causality
of adjacent unfolding events but something
jeez so they're five times fast you're malfunctioning
what you're gonna have to visit weird Barbie
I have never had to visit weird Barbie that's
because you've never malfunctioned who is
weird Barbie beautiful Barbie of all but then
someone played with her too hard in the real
world Sid oh no okay I'm here to understand
this world uh oh my gosh she's like Sid damn
what great sets oh I would never wear heels
picking them on themes of not conforming to
how your societal Norms of how you should
be yeah but being true to who you who you
really are hey what's cooking good looking
was that Kate McKinnon I think so to come
see you about my feet there um
[Laughter] you've opened a portal and now
there is a rift in the Continuum that is the
membrane between Barbie land and the real
world oh no baby girl you gotta go fix it
you're gonna keep going funny look at your
upper thigh gotta go fix it into the Barbie
version cellular that's gonna spread everywhere
and then you're gonna start getting sad and
mushy and complicated no I know you have to
go to the real world and you have to find
the girl who's playing with you oh there's
the girl and the doll and never the twain
shall cross interesting oh wow why would she
be sad we fixed everything so that all women
in the real world can be happy and Powerful
yes I can't have I've only ever wanted for
everything to stay exactly as it is well the
two of you are becoming inextricably intertwined
what interesting she's Tethered to the human
like that is her Barbie like the only person
in her life you can go back to your regular
life or you can know the truth about the universe
the first one the high heel damn it Neo you
have to want to know okay do it again I'm
not Adventure Barbie I'm stereotypical Barbie
I'm like the Barbie you think of when someone
says think of a Barbie
it worked I did that is why she was cast here
I just gave you a choice so you could feel
some sense of control so there is no option
one giving you a choice so you could feel
some sense of control wow
holy crap that's a base [__] oh manipulating
a choice is crazy I'm trying to find reason
s not to leave they're gonna miss you guys
so much I just wish someone could come with
me but you can't now's your time what bird
am I thinking of parrot dolphin I mean no
a bird
you'll get to see all the good work we've
done to fix the world you'll be such a hero
to them I'll bet every woman will say thank
you and give you a really big hug
boiling the movie it's like so vibrant and
uplifting but there's such a melancholic undertone
here at all too it's like a sugary pop song
with sad lyrics introspection
[Music] [Applause] [Laughter] hey Roger Rabbit
I can't I made a double bet with Ken you can't
make me look uncool in front of Ken appears
to me ouch there's so much about his appearance
so insecure I love it did you bring your roller
blades I literally go nowhere without them
please okay where were you hiding those wow
what an adventure
I love a good montage
[Music] no okay don't fly off the space laughs
and we're here the set photos nice this is
30 minutes away from us
I actually think in the real world no one
would bat an eye yeah
I feel kind of abilities like I don't know
the word for it but I'm conscious but it's
myself that I'm conscious of oh I feel what
could only be described as admire
appreciate it I'm such a narcissist [Music]
I would just like to inform you I do not have
a vagina wow whoa oh my goodness we don't
have genitals that's okay yeah I have all
the janitors I have all the genitals one of
each everything's almost like reversed here
I always got a little smile on his face yeah
I get a taste of power
that's what I'm talking about Barbie well
done and again on it that's a little tiny
little and it's great I love Fringe those
are fresh strips where'd they get the money
hey man
she looks even better than real clothes big
pack in jail who is playing with me what am
I supposed to do by myself really where it
reminds me of Michael Scott
it's just so like unbelievably needy he's
got Michael Scott and some of that Nicholas
Cage like wildness like subdued but what's
up man we got a man up on this one great workout
man oh yeah you found the Ken Den smartest
at the center the center piece of image and
security yeah totally and status you could
have done New York also but I like it but
we sell dreams and Illusions here yeah good
stuff so I'm not worried about it not now
Margaret let's Jake on this
learn my son
[Music]
welcome to the Ken triarchy this is what being
a man's all about yeah get your creatine boy
that's what I imagine when I meditate a little
girl don't be a creep John you know just like
nice childhood memory and she dies in a violent
yeah that's why I've been thinking about that
bones burning wreck [Music] okay Goodwill
product placement
the mark of a good actor training my ducts
it's interesting she steps into the real world
and she's getting a dose of the hardship of
being a woman yeah Ken's getting what it's
like when men are put on a pedestal and behind
the power they get yeah yeah when men are
the form in control yeah [Music]
there's an array of emotions out there and
everyone is experiencing them you're old Barbie
oh I know it oh is she the Creator yeah it's
great at girl work this is critical wig inventor
of Barbie okay
welcome
oh and the reality that men are controlling
Barbie yeah yeah somewhere in a boardroom
even if a woman invented it this happened
before a woman named Skipper turned up at
some family's home in Key West asked to babysit
the kids whoa is that a reference to a skipper
movie you may never come back I know I love
the way they're portraying the Mattel Corporation
right now
wow this feels like we're stepping into a
Black Mirror episode now oh it's her yeah
she's grown up just started drawing these
weird designs these are different it's irrepressible
thoughts of death Barbie full body cellulite
Barbie no one wants this reality Barbie is
my internal monologue Barbie they're in a
big corporate idea session no one is to be
admitted oh my God are we going to get the
purest Taste of capitalism where they'd actually
put these toys out eating disorder bar really
you can buy them now and when you take a sparkle
what do you think after that female agency
yes one comes right after the other let's
get all these Kens
oh Jesus
Warner Brothers Discovery logos in the back
geez everything has this like Center frame
yeah if this got out that our dolls were coming
to Los Angeles from Barbie land Barbie in
the real world that's impossible you created
this awesome anymore is Barbie land like an
alternate reality or is it like a place where
uh your imagination is yes [Laughter] whatever
you think it is you're right I've started
to get all these weirdo feelings like I have
fear with no specific object what do anxiety
you need to find her soon I'm just gonna pop
into the library and see if I can find any
books on trucks okay just don't get in trouble
I won't they're like brother and sister too
like they bicker like kids who are you I'm
only your favorite woman of all time Barbie
hated dolls with hair I mean I played with
Barbie but it was like the last resort I loved
Barbie
no you didn't you've been making women feel
bad about themselves since you were invented
you've represent everything wrong with her
culture sexualized capitalism unrealistic
physical life no no go for it describing something
stereotypical Barbie is so much more than
that it was the stereotype you destroy girls
innate sense of worth and you are killing
the planet with your glorification of rampant
consumerism
and until you showed up here and declared
yourself Barbie I hadn't thought about you
in years you fascist wow fascist Barbie get
a taste of that gen Z oh I'm gonna stop yelling
at my Barbie dolls you know what I yeah we
should all treat our Barbies nicer be more
compassionate to them [Music] why man rule
sir do you have the time you respect me sorry
no do you know what time it is
why didn't Barbie tell me about patriarchy
which to my understanding is where men and
horses run everything sure oh my I'll take
a high level high paying job with influence
please okay you'll need at least an NBA isn't
being a man enough actually right now it's
kind of the opposite you guys are clearly
not doing patriarchy very well yeah we're
doing it well yeah we just uh hide it better
now yeah oh you want to be a lifeguard I'm
trained to stand confidently right here there's
nobody in danger here and even if there were
I'm not trained to save them [Laughter]
can still have to work hard Ken I need to
find somewhere where I can start patriarchy
fresh
oh my poor Mattel everything is backwards
here men look at me like I'm an object girls
hate me everyone thinks I'm crazy and I keep
getting arrested I'll go back to Barbie land
and I'll tell the Ken's what I've learned
oh it's going to be beautiful oh oh my God
is Ken gonna become a villain is Ken gonna
become like a dictator reality challenged
woman she thinks she's Barbie what did you
say she thinks she's Barbie what are you doing
that's her Barbie [Music] you worked there
yeah just catch up [Laughter] you're so happy
to see you would you like some mineral one
yes thank you
if you could just get into that giant box
you know what we should probably get Ken first
you know Ken Barbie and Ken Ken get the guy
yeah the guy Ken isn't something we're worried
about ever could I just meet the woman in
charge oh that would be me oh you're CFO me
your c-o-o here president of the Barbie division
I'm a man with no power does that make me
a woman [Music] nope we have gender neutral
bathrooms up the Wazoo every single one of
these men love women I'm the son of a mother
I'm the mother of a son I'm I'm the nephew
of a woman aunt true facts Progressive get
in the Box you Jezebel yes jeez you filthy
oh and I've been real priesty and flashback
get in the Box damn that is Icky oh no oh
the restrainment the twist ties not the twist
ties could I just run to the restroom and
make sure my hair is perfect here's an underlying
horror to this film oh definitely these guys
are so creepy I guess you really had to go
to the bathroom yep that was a really unsettling
thing but with the box and the rest I feel
like there's a lot something much deeper there
well yeah it feels like poisoned nice guy
Femme feminism like foreign
daring Escape Plan Barbie actually is like
a a tinge of a Sci-Fi touch to it so I think
the 2001 opening is pretty pretty emblematic
of the experience here because it's a reflection
on a reality don't worry you're safe here
whoa what is this place it is a Black Mirror
quality
learning to drink she's just learning how
to be real world isn't what I thought it was
that happens a lot and isn't that marvelous
Discovery is she the Creator I'm just gonna
ask that every time an older woman shows up
on screen I think probably Ruth thank you
Ruth Ruth there you go yeah I forget what
her last name is but yeah I think the Creator's
name is Ruth we got her there she is
a minute ago
come on come with me if you want to live
these guys are so petty little lonely lately
be joyful was it no it wasn't the power of
imagination and then the drawings got sad
and weird and maybe because I couldn't be
like you I ended up making you like me I came
for you those were your memories it's like
a Westworld Flair to this [__] man so
weird many colliding movies a sci-fi movie
it is it's a sci-fi film hello are you two
like Shining this is weird weird commentary
about creation yeah creation play bonding
and the power of imagination as well boring
mom with a boring job and a daughter who hates
me can you blame me for wanting to have a
little fun I gotta lose these chuckleheads
when you need somebody to project onto just
as much as to inspire you especially when
you're feeling alone and cut off from a loved
one I do like how they they wrote Barbie to
be like [__] she's very she has a strong
vocabulary her vernacular is very wide-ranging
yeah yeah she's intelligent yeah whoa
Barbie when Imaginary Land yeah because I
never get to do anything I didn't even go
on that cruise I wanted your school raffle
because I didn't have enough vacation days
and your dad's allergic to sign what graphos
killing it killing it Ken
to it a little set make your own choices Woman
as a man I give you permission I urge you
to do all the things I can even though I've
set it up at a skew [Music] it's like the
Barbie world is a fantasy idea yeah for for
girls to hold on to and it just leads to them
being depressed because it's not the reality
yeah yeah they can never get back there I
totally understand it I feel it I grew up
with it my inner little girl's satiated by
that totally get it that's strange oh no Ken
what have you done
incoming brewsky beer president what happened
to you Ken has introduced the male patriarchy
he's introduced the male gays whoa have a
brewsky beer my big guy is thirsty a brewsky
bear wait until you see my dream house everything
I've bought and owned will totally inspire
you and we can change clothes again that's
the capital oh this is Turtle no cat is a
villain
oh my God Mount Rush horse there was a minute
where I thought it was run by horses but then
I realized that horses are just men extenders
yes
compensate for whatever you need
oh my God everything exists to expand and
Elevate the presence of men it's beautiful
this is beautiful wow this is my dream house
it is my dream house it's mine no this is
no longer Barbie be known as Ken's Mojo Dojo
Casa house try it Mojo Dojo Casa house Mojo
Dojo Casa house houses are literally flying
off the shelf the kids are clambering for
them they're still pink are boys buying it
I guess which is already a black buster hit
yes oh this movie's brilliant yeah it's brilliant
it stopped provoking as hell but also very
accessible yeah really fun yeah but still
not leaving like no punch bowl no stone unturned
for my long-term low commitment distance girlfriend
I love that we just pick up the embodiment
of masculine toxicity the ultimate Chad yes
I know isn't it great and Alan likes to help
me give all the Ken's foot massages no I don't
I don't like that we love it uh and it's going
to be just like Century City in Los Angeles
because they had it all figured out Century
City no no no they don't have it figured out
in Century City because we failed them no
you failed me wow out there I was somebody
people respected me just for who I am you
just wanted approval ouch and if it weren't
for these technicalities like NBAs I could
have ruled that world but I don't need any
of those things here I'm just a dude I'm just
a dude living in kentivity I love that it
became a villain yeah I love that choice I
love it and now you're making it permanent
with a special election to change the Constitution
awesome with all the council ahead to the
polls and vote to change the Constitution
to a government for the Kens of the cans and
by the cans oh my God this is so many layers
deep I can't believe it oh my God how's that
feeling it is not fun is it I don't recall
her ever being this cruel yeah I mean the
patriarchy has existed long before Barbie
got he's like bullying yeah Brown beating
oh she's crying in Barbie land take your lady
Fashions with you
why did you wish me to your messed up world
using your Barbie's land was perfect before
I was perfect before I've never wanted anything
to change that's life it's constant only thing
in life that's constant that's terrifying
yeah really understand this feeling it's basically
like being a human person all the time
very much
okay you know I almost feel bad
moving like he only got four joints
it's much more repulsive R rated to pray version
of this movie out there
the endless possibilities time to run out
yes no they're doing it yes and
in time until she falls asleep they're doing
the thing I thought they were gonna do
[Music]
Bond we interrupt this broadcast to bring
you our new radio station only playing Ken's
favorite song
this Matchbox 20.
tomorrow [Music]
I cannot sit on one more leather couch it's
gonna break my spirit as soon as they figure
out how to build that wall sideways and not
just up no one is going to be able to get
in or out
[Laughter] one person would care if Ellen
was in the real world in fact it's happened
before all of NSYNC Allen
all offense beautiful I'm Ken's buddy yeah
all his clothes fit me
you've been hanging out with Kung Fu bar give
me Scott Pilgrim back yeah Alan earned the
power of self-respect even if you can't make
it perfect you can mimic anything better I'm
the one who ruined Barbie land with my stupid
drawings in the first time I'm not stupid
they're amazing you're amazing Mom they're
weird and dark and crazy everything you pretend
not to be hmm being authentic to your true
self let's go get my dog [Music]
the hair whip he did all that ass kicking
for none just run to the real world yourself
Alan you're in Magic again this is sugar and
I'm her daddy oh it's and I have an earring
a magic carrier uh they're cameos no he's
the guy from the trip I know his name Rob
Ryden I'm not an idiot anymore oh I'm not
stereotypical Barbie pretty note to the filmmakers
Margot Robbie is the wrong person to cast
if you want to make this point
it's about the feeling
I'm brilliant I'm not the president no one
on the Supreme Court is me I'm not good enough
for anything
he's such a great actress yeah it is literally
impossible to be a woman we have to always
be extraordinary but somehow we're always
doing it wrong yeah what's up with that guys
get this together come on fix this and you
can never say you want to be thin you have
to say you want to be healthy but also you
have to be thin so you you do understand yeah
it was a program Chop Chop ladies you have
to lead but you can't squash other people's
ideas you're supposed to love being a mother
but don't talk about your kids all the damn
time you have to be a career woman but also
always be looking out for other people answer
for men's bad behavior which is insane but
if you point that out you're accused of complaining
I know it bothers me yeah should you guys
please keep it down other women because you're
supposed to be a part of The Sisterhood but
always stand out and always be grateful woof
this is really a great speech this is bars
you have to never get old never be rude never
show off never get out of line it's too hard
it's too contradictory and nobody gives you
thank you are you doing everything wrong but
also everything is your fault wow a man must
have written this no Obama
yo here he goes directed the movie
and if all of
them it's like they want to put women into
a box I did write a book like I've been in
a dream where I was somehow really invested
in the Zack Snyder cut of Justice League who's
wrong with that what did this move this River
just lost
you need to say all of those things to the
other Barbies that's the key okay here's the
deal it's not just about how they see us it's
about how they see themselves exactly distract
them by appearing helpless and Confused pens
cannot resist a damseling distress no we cannot
we can't anything to prop ourselves up to
look like a savior shop is so hard I just
don't understand how to use the select tool
honey you can only use the select tool if
Polaris highlighted you have to be their mommies
but not remind them of their mommy any power
you have must be masked under a giggle oh
my God yes amen sister you can tell him that
you've never seen The Godfather and that you'd
love them to explain it to you can you start
the movie over and just talk through the whole
thing video essay can talk to you oh my god
I'd be mad if this movie wasn't so accurate
it's fascinating that this corporate product
is like the least corporate infusion of feminist
ideas
I love it it's based AF I am so awkward and
don't feel pretty at all and will anyone ever
like me distract them until wearing glasses
glasses cover that you're pretty
no like the way they Riff on the genres of
this aesthetic it uses older Cinema genres
to Riff on the aesthetic of the way we romanticize
and idealize stuff yeah yeah and the yeah
interplay between the Sexes over the years
against each other you make them question
whether they have enough power over each other
it's like I'm a woman already welcome it's
what it's like you're coming of age
hi oh Jesus tidied up oh hey you've caught
me reading my man I'm ready to be here long-term
distance low commitment casual girlfriend
if you'll still have me oh nice I could tell
you
okay come on in I'll play the guitar at you
play the guitar at you as it was meant to
be played oh is this one [Music] I'm a little
bit of rustier and I don't know
four hours of Rob Thomas boys
[Laughter]
hilarious
[Music]
Jesus
[Music] who are you texting no one let me
just John dang it's a beautiful song that
you're playing you play on their egos and
their Petty jealousies and you turn them against
each other they're gonna stop I gotta work
so well Petty jealousies would keep the country
moving yes the fragile glue that holds us
all together in the machine doesn't seem to
matter [Music] always number two no one knows
how hard I tried those pecks into it boy all
my life been so polite but I'll sleep alone
tonight I'm just kidding [Music]
you're in the Ken Zone storm the beach at
Burgundy
gonna be a Mexican I like how this stays adherent
to the rules of the world yeah [Applause]
and like the shopping cart formations pink
a post-apocalyptic [Music] kick his ass yeah
can Foo [Music]
yeah the other side were there real weapons
here no no
whoever is like in an 80s musical action yeah
yes [Music]
[Laughter] this is awesome and two that the
big evil plan like culminates in this musical
number like
so childish
[Laughter]
this is the best [Music]
Yo he's buried in this my name's Kane
so am I
doubt [Music]
all those in favor of letting Barbie land
be Barbie land
I now go change the real world yes can we
get a reproduction of this outside I'm so
happy in a world full of Ken's being Allen
these Mojo Dojo Casa houses just get dreamier
weird ADR okay that's because their dream
houses mother [Music] with the Mattel logo
don't look at me oh
are you okay yeah
I cried too it's actually kind of amazing
I'm a liberated man I know crying's not weak
true buddy when I found out that patriarchy
wasn't about horses I lost interest anyway
oh you just love horses I always thought this
would be our house poor guy I'm really sorry
I took you for granted oh I just don't know
who I am without you it's time to find out
that's a good thing I only exist within the
warmth of your gays whoa without it blood
God I can't do flips oh same man maybe it's
Barbie and it's Ken Ken
yes me yes can is me if you're like an ape
me am Ken Ken
fojo Mojo mink we were only fighting because
we didn't know who we were wow
strong maybe psychological political emotional
thanks to the Barbies I too can now relieve
myself of this heavy existential burden while
holding on to the very real title of CEO and
the pay package that comes with it please
may the Kens have one Supreme Court Justice
oh I can't do that ouch but maybe a lower
circuit court judge the Kens will have as
much power and influence in Barbie land as
women have in the real world
okay what about ordinary Barbie that's it
it's a terrible idea yeah that's going to
be money oh oh ordinary Barbie I love it [Laughter]
she's in love with Ken that is not her ending
what do you want I don't know I'm make her
own choices I want to figure it out I don't
think I have an ending that was always the
point I created you so you wouldn't have an
ending I really feel
like come walk with me we're going to the
Stream
thank you I am good enough you am Kenneth
humans make things up like patriarchy and
Barbie just to deal with how uncomfortable
it is then you die fun comfortable I I want
to do the imagining I don't want to be the
idea I always knew that Barbie would surprise
me but I never expected this AI bar movie
don't you control me you're a Barbie dog control
you any more than I could control my own daughter
I named you after her Barbara is she really
the Creator she's a good actress I know I
was just like she used to make an appearances
huh I used to flow now take your first breath
like Pinocchio samachus Pinocchio
[Music] and so much experience they grab home
movies from other different casts or did people
send these in from all over the world yes
yes she made the choice yeah and the answer
or was it an illusion the soft part of the
Matrix you got this I'm really proud of you
that's a political statement that's appropriation
[Music] the sandals name oh um Handler comma
Barbara Barbara Handler I'm here to see my
gynecologist
one woman's anatomical completion
wow oh and they even got the aqua remix nice
credits oh Emerald fennel is Midge okay yeah
yeah are these real uh yeah at the real Allen
Allen he's Ken's buddy Helen Mirren was the
narrator did not pick up on that oh yeah yeah
Ruth Handler yeah I don't know uh Barbie history
guys so
wow that pooping dog was there were some very
peculiar toys out there sugars daddy God
I remember mermaid Barbie and your Barbie
world in there
that's great can't wait to talk about it no
yeah that was next level all right kick us
off John well uh and during the the little
break there I looked it up and uh the real
Ruth Handler died in 2002 so that was not
Ruth okay um but that was that was quite an
experience that like it's been you know making
these waves in the world and you come into
a movie like this and you're like okay you
know I don't know really what to expect exactly
aside from the trailer in terms of specifics
but you know how is this going to deliver
what kind of conversation is it going to have
after all this buzz and this was a really
wonderfully kind of mad cap but also yeah
emotional and thought-provoking experience
in a way that you know really pulled me up
in its own ride I think from the outside you
know you see and you go like oh there's stuff
that looks like The Lego Movie and things
that are gonna comment on you know like purpose
and existentiality if that's a word um but
it does so in a very different way coming
from what feels like a very different place
and maybe a bit of a more challenging place
than simply innocence like it deals with that
but I feel like yeah there's so many layers
from you know just the personal to the political
to the existential the philosophical all that
stuff um so yeah this was another kind of
recent movie experience I can think of that's
like oh yeah this is kind of like so many
of the things that Cinema can be and also
it's having a very interesting and I think
well uh conceived conversation through all
these you know Fantastical silly and humorous
elements and whatnot um so I mean yeah I was
I was quite gripped and disconcerted all at
the same time I guess I would say yeah uh
the the movie has brilliant I think it's a
genius film uh I'm surprised by it because
it's like yeah any although the conversation
about like it made a billion dollars and it's
the biggest movie of the year you know and
overtaken Mario it's overtaken everything
and and I I did I definitely I avoided a reviews
I avoided everything on it because I just
didn't want to get any opinions kind of influencing
my own I wanted this to be fresh I had no
idea about this Descent of Ken I thought was
great because the movie's very accessible
and it's like while I I bet there's a lot
of deeper I mean yeah there's a lot of things
in here that are are deeper and more subtle
and I'm sure there's things that probably
flew over my head this first time watching
it I'm sure there's probably a lot of things
just a guy that I've I probably just can't
truly comprehend or understand right yet there's
yet there's so much in here with this messaging
that is very direct like you could you could
weirdly see how this is a very mature adult
film yet you could also see how it's one that
a family can also at the same time weirdly
watch even though like a PG-13 it's like a
PG-13 kind of family film yeah because there
there's some subjects that are like okay yeah
that's way too young um but you know I like
I don't want to speak for like the right attainable
ages for like a little girl the right age
that is a parent's decision of when to show
this for a child right I can see how it is
very educational and informative at the same
time because there there's a lot of things
that are very overt there's a lot of things
that like a lot of this is very direct they're
just flat out saying it and while I know there's
been parts of the internet that have been
very much up in arms about it and then like
you know I've seen like certain titles of
like it hates men or whatever um I I didn't
get that impression uh at all I I really did
it I think that this movie has a very brilliant
commentary and I think the reason why it still
clicks so much with with a worldwide audience
why even though it is like the woke us of
the woke the kind of film it is you know of
what we say is woke now you know yeah of what
we Define as that is is because that's the
movie the movie's about that it's not trying
to be subtle in that it is it's like front
and center with this film in all aspects that's
dialogue it's every every bit of this film
is all about that and I I think it's when
a movie is trying to like mask it in a way
or or try to be like they're in subtle hints
or whatever nah this movie is is embracing
it from beginning to end and I feel like that's
why it clicks so well because it has this
rewatch capability and so much Nuance that
you could pick up on because it's dealing
with all kinds of things you know uh obviously
self-acceptance The Power of Choice uh the
patriarchy of How It's been harmful to woman
how it's also been harmful to men uh self-reflection
gender stereotypes it's so many different
things that it's just like it interweaving
throughout uh through the reflection like
through the Brilliance of doing this for like
a Barbie adaptation because the first like
half hour you know because of the hype surrounding
it I was here going like I'm enjoying this
this is fun uh why is this the billion dollar
phenomenon that it is yeah and then it then
I I want to say it was around the pudding
in the Box moment that really started to to
do a massive change in my Noggin on it and
then also the hint at what they were doing
with Ken that he's getting exposed to the
patriarchy and the the juxtaposition of seeing
the the reality of how the Barbie land is
this is the is the upside down world of the
real world of you know like women here are
are the dominance that they have they have
the power went on and then her watching how
the mirroring effect is happening I thought
was just so genius and so unexpected because
even not knowing at all what they were gonna
do with the Barbie and Ken relationship not
having any clue prior I was definitely under
the impression that it was still going to
be a romantic comedy yeah I thought that's
what we were getting into I still thought
it was gonna be a romance so I thought the
direction that it took was so surprising and
I I love how it prayed on the um of how the
insecurity of men can often form into something
that is violent and dangerous totally you
know 100 and it's it's true though it's very
very true yeah but they also make fun of like
the modern day man like he has a line in there
I'm like what does he say like I'm a liberal
man I'm a liberated man I'm okay with crying
you know yeah yeah that's not a sign of weakness
yeah they make fun of that and that is it
that is a modern part of our progression too
and um I I thought that the because because
at the end of the day it's that while this
movie has so much messaging throughout as
just a film it's a very entertaining one it's
like that's the that's the thing is like there's
some movies out there where I can walk away
and be like no I I get it I just didn't like
the experience sure you know because some
films are all about its meaning and not really
about what about the enjoyment Factor like
was I invested in the characters did I enjoy
the plot you know and and this is one of those
movies where I thought they did it all I thought
that it had all its deeper meanings it had
its great messaging it had it's it's genius
infused commentary but at the same time it
still had characters I was very much endeared
to I loved every second Barbie and Ken were
on screen you know Ryan Gosling and Margot
Robbie specifically obviously uh when they
were on screen I liked America ferreira's
character a lot um I I thought the plot was
very engaging the visuals were extremely Dynamic
the music was exceptional uh the the direction
in cinematography was awesome so as it's just
a film it's a it's a very engaging one and
then it's got stuff where it's like the messaging
is very on the nose but it's kind of the point
and then it's it's got stuff where it's it's
deeper than you might expect and then these
like little nuggets of lines and I'm like
wow that line is a bar right there that line
hits home so yeah man I loved it I thought
it was I thought it was great my only real
things that I didn't quite care for um there
was something about the Will Ferrell stuff
that I didn't love I don't know what it was
it seemed like that maybe could have used
maybe an extra beat button or some kind of
I I don't know it there's something about
them that feels almost tangential and what
really matters is what's going on in Barbie
land between the Barbies and the cans and
that's essentially the reality that we're
mostly subject to and by the end they're like
I thought they were gonna try and I don't
know I thought they would be perturbed that
things were going back to normal and that
they would try and push the kingdom you know
uh agendum further or something like that
and I mean like I thought they had a sharp
you know a sharp bit at the end with her pitching
normal person Barbie and then him going like
that's a terrible idea oh wait it's gonna
sell fine which is a nice commentary on corporate
wokeness but um but yeah I don't know there
was something about those characters that
seemed like they were the most cartoony and
the most like it's a bit out of everything
in the movie and all the fake neon characters
were the most alive and engaging and yeah
I mean it does feel just kind of like a different
Riff on Lord Business in a way I felt uh I
guess I felt the least
I was like I know the ideas did not be inventive
about them um I think it lacked at a movie
filled with creativity and cleverness it was
the one part that was lacking in it for me
it went about is the execution of them was
about as what I expected when I saw the trailer
yeah where everything else yeah everything
else kind of surprised me yeah where they
were I'm like I feel like I've seen this portrayal
of CEO dumb guys before who um you're just
like dumb yes men yeah yeah yeah so that was
the only part of it that that was that didn't
exactly quite uh click for me and it is a
bit of like a a cameo Galore Fest where they
didn't really utilize some people like there's
like there's no real point in using John Cena
I mean I think it's one of those things where
you're at a point where so many people are
are it's got such a stacked Ensemble that
it's like ah why not you know this person
wants to come by throw them in but yeah I
mean you know you expect maybe some kind of
additional bits with them maybe they're a
lot of I would expect like maybe there are
a lot of deleted scenes and things like that
too just with like fun stuff that we couldn't
include for pacing or whatever yeah um but
yeah no like this this to me had that quintessential
movie Magic quality where it is talking to
you and it does have a perspective and it's
also the culmination of so much physical and
intellectual Artistry and thought and Poise
and it used everything I know as an outsider
as a person who never played with Barbie it
used everything I know about that uh and then
multiplied it by and I think took it uh interesting
cues from just the idea again of playing as
a kid and what that means and why and kind
of likening that to what adults are experiencing
because you know in in ways you're still looking
to this thing for Comfort you're still projecting
onto it you're still in some ways taking inspiration
from it and it's one of the earliest ways
we learn some of these interactions in some
of the earliest ways that as kids we can you
know unlock what's really going on inside
yeah and then you know passing those things
off and giving them away Through The Eyes
of the daughter you know is as you come of
age and then having Barbie come of age uh
I don't know yeah it made for like a fascinating
blame even though you do spend so much time
in this fantasy world it made for a fascinating
blend of human themed like it's obviously
overt in terms of like the socio-political
conversation that it's having but it's also
really encompassing of just the again stress
and chaos and confusion of being alive and
the ways in which we expand and contract just
our vulnerability and who we are truly as
people as we navigate this world that is set
up in a way that feels so shiny and official
and you know regimented and yet truly at the
end of the day is not and never will be and
so I think it it encompassed just that all
around chaos and and existential uh you know
angst of being alive and trying to figure
out why you're feeling all the things that
you're feeling and I love the alley-oop expecting
like oh it's gonna be Amer America Ferreira
it was it's her doll or something like that
and then you know she's a little girl grown
up I thought having the mother-daughter story
and having those two perspectives uh represented
as well and you see kind of the start of you
know the difficulty that coming of age can
be through that daughter that also is going
on through Barbie but also the wistful memory
of what has been and what could have been
through the mom and things like that and the
things that you know maybe you [__] down
so that you could appear more together or
with it and two then just commenting on like
well what's Barbie's role in our actual world
and you know what is the importance maybe
or the detriment maybe of a toy that is pitched
one or another way and uh and that matches
really well with the subject of the movie
itself so it's I think this is one of those
really nice kind of Nexus point films where
what it's doing makes a lot of sense but it
also matches the subject in the narrative
as well as the subject outside of the narrative
and it's all gleefully mad cap and it has
just the right right amount of like creeping
Terror at certain points or just this sense
that like things are off or Sinister and yeah
that whole thing with getting the box and
let us tie you down you know and pose you
the exact way we want to and the back and
forth between you know a problematic figure
like a Barbie where so much of the history
is like men making money but also pretending
or at least being behooved because it makes
money to encourage you know women and girls
too blah blah blah yeah I like the Barbie
Arc a lot because what she's learning to be
human uh in a way that's about embracing imperfection
and embracing the the the pain and the Sorrows
that come with being human and embracing the
anxieties but also what the power and the
reward and catharsis is of overcoming and
the the true development of strength that
comes from fighting for something and then
coming out on on top but also just dealing
with any kind of really it just comes down
to just the Embrace of experience you know
like that's why I loved how nothing really
seemed like her learning to be human came
down to anything that was about materialistic
you know like there was a good amount of emphasis
on the the relief of of crying and how the
expression of Tears is actually something
that can be very rewarding and and feel very
good yeah everything about it was just about
human experience and embracing that uh even
for Ken you know like it was cool how they
had two very different Journeys one that was
very reflective of males and the other reflective
of women and yet they still landed on the
same spot which is we have to just know who
we are yeah you know and and that should be
the thing that comes first and and foremost
and understanding individualism as well is
so important because so much of this is about
being influenced by what Society Norms are
like you see that with Ken you know because
he's just a lost boy you know yeah and I I
loved that they they managed to tell two very
different stories with them but also like
it's stemming from how it stems from perfect
Barbie as we all know the perfect doll and
then yeah and then there's cats yeah yeah
Ken who was just created for party you know
yeah and it turns a compassionate eye toward
that stuff and I think that's where I can
yeah you hear all these people being like
Oh the movie hates men and Ken is they made
him such a you know lame character or a character
that we're supposed to laugh at who isn't
really cool but like history of Barbie and
Ken actually not being that cool aside I think
they did it nicely to yeah portray him as
this very insecure and very sort of petty
guy but look at what is beneath that and what
a [__] and the fact and the fact that
I think like people get offended by that like
Get over yourself yeah exactly right and there
are people like this and oftentimes especially
like alpha males who are you know preaching
the the word of men's rights and things like
that are often fixated on women even still
and they're often just Pawns in a greater
again machine that is yeah is kind of giving
you various benefits kind of off the bat but
at the same time is not actually necessarily
empowering you or giving you you know the
things you need to just yet live your most
fulfilled life for real and there's so many
distractions I feel like yeah like in the
way Society works right now there are so many
ways men can fall into these toxic traps and
become you know the kingdom that we see here
because yeah there's a lot of pent-up emotion
and this feeling of yeah I mean even though
it's very different in the ways men and women
experience it and and what power that allots
in society there's still this sense of I'm
supposed to be extraordinary and unique and
yet I'm just one of like a bunch of their
millions of me there are millions of people
everywhere what is my purpose what do I do
and yeah it was obviously changed a good amount
and continues to in terms of what we're able
to acknowledge and express but for so long
it has been that thing of you know you just
have it together and you keep that stiff upper
lift and you and you and you you lead with
your strong masculine qualities and you're
fine and that's what life is for and it's
not you know it's it's another box you know
it's another pose that they're trying to make
and two I mean even though uh it's that same
kind of thing it's like you're not just defined
by your job and even though there's a bunch
of different Kens with a bunch of different
jobs you're just you at the end of the day
and yeah it's only one part I guess it's just
all kind of Testament to how like life is
so many things and you cannot just be one
and it will never just always be the same
and there is no kind of blissful uh you know
Plato's perfect heaven where things just continue
on in you know Perfection and you're always
sated and content and happy um and yeah like
it's very different the way men experience
life in society but I think a lot of that
on both sides is encompassed here and it's
also very of the now while being kind of Timeless
within those themes well and I think too uh
Mattel is genius for green lighting this for
now yeah because uh it's also a fantastic
advertisement for Barbie
on the darkest level it is as much as this
is about like it's it's not it it is it is
a com one of the many commentaries is about
is of course How uh of the many things is
also talking about corporations and all that
and at the same time and like how corporations
have negatively affected us is with with like
the image of the standards of Barbie and whatever
it is still a brilliant advertisement to get
more Barbie and Ken and get the Margot Robbie
stereotypical barf and like the movie goes
down that path with like oh we're selling
the the damaged woman Barbie brand right now
you know yeah and I'm like but I feel like
if they sold it in real life people would
buy it especially the heels of this movie
especially deals of a billion dollar hit like
I have a I have a Ken Barbie doll right now
yes you do like I'm jealous the thing is it's
also like wow what a what a what a kind of
a a sinistered plan of like hey it's still
it's a little great attitude we can still
sell this [__] you know yeah yeah one
that's the thing it's even kind of encompassed
in the film because it's one of those things
where it's like if we didn't know that so
many of the boxes that we're checking are
already gonna net us a profit you know then
we probably wouldn't be on board for all the
things you want to say but because it's probably
gonna make maybe we don't know it's gonna
make a billion so it's probably going to make
a good amount of money given all of our resources
yeah say whatever you want yeah we'll only
get involved when we think it's gonna hurt
the bottom line and it's yeah it's a bit of
a unicorn because we live in a time where
there is so much kind of trite stiff or awkward
uh incorporation of hate what the conversations
turn the word woke into so I'm just going
to say like enlightened principles are often
pitched in these movies and Blockbusters that
is the wokest thing you could have ever said
John just trying to be basic just trying to
be as based as I can be but you know we get
a lot of really trite and kind of eye roll
worthy uh uh you know lip service to equality
and various things in our media and this is
not doing that this is bothering to go the
full depth and so while this is literally
a giant commercial product uh at the same
time yeah it is kind of allowed to be all
that it can be and that's a special thing
and I you know am ever fascinated by how these
things slip through in the form that they
do and then it often does just come down to
it will make money so it's fine say whatever
you want yeah um but it really does you know
speak wider than you would expect and and
as you know I expected something good something
with some intelligence something with some
subtext but you know this was kind of always
exploring that stuff it never took a break
really just to be fun past a certain point
once you're established with everything and
so yeah it's like you can just enjoy it on
that level if you want to but you can enjoy
it for so many others as well and I think
too the reason it has made as much as as it
has is because it is speaking universally
even though definitely the Battle of the Sexes
is so embraced by the plot and well ingrained
in the imagery and the happenings of the movie
and all that stuff you know it does appeal
like Barbie's journey is universal as well
in some ways maybe not as much but Ken's is
two and especially it's like Barbie having
the crisis of like I can be kind of anything
and this is still not solving everything and
can coming into our world and being like this
is kind of the one thing that we're supposed
to do you know it all kind of leads to a mess
at the end and uh yeah it's wonderfully Lifey
and also like yeah it seems like they really
pulled nope punches with this script at all
or didn't think franchise which is fascinating
too when you think Mattel was wise enough
to approve all this and now they want to make
16 movies based on all their other toys so
like what did they understand this to begin
with you know there are various kind of capitalist
hellscape questions to ask yourself but in
this moment this is yeah no I doubt that the
any any future Mattel movie is going to be
as good as this no no no no no this is this
is way too like Greta Gerwig and and Noah
bombach's voice Greta go rig especially though
like her voice is is one of the main stars
of this movie oh yeah totally um so yeah congratulations
to everyone involved I'm Barbie uh like I
think all the success and praise as well well
deserved oh this is a very unique experience
and for of finally getting a live action adaptation
of Barbie being brought to life uh this is
the last thing I think anyone really expected
because it is weird it is strange it's odd
it's Fantastical it's a little bit horror
it's a little bit sci-fi but it's great I
thought it was a fantastic film and meta without
being obnoxious references without being obnoxious
yeah yeah yeah alrighty guys well what did
you think of Barbie did you love it leave
your thoughts down below and hey before we
go let's end this with a patron of the day
shout out I'm on Saturday Nisa Oliva John
if she was a Barbie doll what would you do
ah I wanna push you around well how will well
how will Anisa come over to come come back
to California so we can Beach all right that's
what we need to do is we need to go Beach
and then I'll sing it to you for four straight
hours and if you check yourself I am gonna
cry sadly she would love that don't check
your phone because we're meant to be it's
on the box Anissa and John sold separately
Batteries Not Included intended for ages five
to nine
you got a little more on you come on I love
you Anisa you should stay pledged so that
we can well someday let all the pledge money
goes to I didn't want to tell you this before
but I'm building your Malibu Dream Castle
all right here in the great state of Los Angeles
land is dirt cheap and uh it's being erected
as we speak it's got a swirly uh Pool slide
it's got your pink Corvette it's got uh the
dog that poops candies I hope uh that's there
it's all there and every day we'll have a
party and you'll be president and I will uh
you know just hang out on the beach all day
and wait for you and wait and wait for you
and wait for you some more and then when you
get there my life will have meaning again
and we can have fun on the beach and I'll
sing you a song that goes like this I wanna
push you around
I wanna push you down well I'm going to no
Harmony it's okay it's all right I was thinking
about other stuff it's my only it's that's
it's that's my song all right you get your
own song that you can sing to Olivia but Anissa
and I we're gonna go live in the Malibu dream
house together
videos it's done now right that's never done
no it's it was done a couple of minutes ago
I'm going to the real world [Music]